[Musique]
alphonse mouche à un style unique celui
d'un homme en prise avec les aspirations
d'un siècle naissant un homme tendue
aussi vers la cause d'un peuple le
peuple slave qui ne cessa de nourrir la
vie d'un artiste d'exception le style ou
chat et l'effet de plusieurs sources de
plusieurs influences et j'ai envie de
dire de plusieurs aspirations c'est
d'abord un style décoratif qui se veut
accessible immédiat dans lequel on peut
rentrer facilement donc séduisant fait
donc d'un dispositif qui globalement
reprend toujours une figure féminine
draper parfois avec un peu de dignité
inséré dans un ensemble d'éléments
naturels naturaliste plus ou moins
stylisée qui l'en chasser qui eux-mêmes
utilise beaucoup la courbe la boucle
donc une boucle qui donne une espèce de
dynamisme circulaire avec une petite
pointe qui part pour donner un peu de
piquant d'asymétrie à l'ensemble un
les lignes s'entrecroiser découpe les
modèles micha marque la toute la
singularité de son geste
elles sont cernés et en même temps c'est
un style un peu vitrail au fond cette
compartimentation comme si le plomb en
chasser ces figures qui donne une espèce
d'arrière plan religieux lumineux aussi
à ce style et est donc une aura très
frappante et qui va au delà de cette
espèce de sensualité immédiates qu'elles
sont par ailleurs
[Musique]
oh
une sensualité formidablement maîtriser
bugeat est un maître du trait ce trait
qui décide la vie et la nature une
maîtrise façonné d'une enfance morave
jusqu'aux ateliers parisiens
il a une facilité incroyable on sent que
c'est un artiste c'est pas beaucoup de
repentir qui dessinent du premier coup
de crayon exactement justement un sens
des proportions infaillible alors il a
dessiné très tout il un parcours à la
fois d'autodidacte et académiques
traditionnelles
il a étudié un peu à vienne il a
travaillé dans une entreprise de décors
de théâtre
ensuite il est allé à l'académie de
munich et il a voulu poursuivre sa
formation à paris dans l'académie julian
colarossi
[Musique]
dans le paris de la belle époque la
fiche envahi les rues et les boulevards
toute la capitale se pare d'un art
inédit on l'appelle déjà l'art nouveau
l'uja a vraiment créé ce style d'
affiches art nouveau dans lequel il a
apporté une singularité par rapport à
ses contemporains affichiste qui est
vraiment de de doubler les faits très
stylisé qui est propre à l'art nouveau
de une transfiguration de la nature en a
un objet très très graphique avec un
naturalisme assez fort et toujours
respectueux de la figure
[Musique]
un coup du destin que cette rencontre
avec sarah bernhardt la tragédienne
règne sur paris elle fera de musa le
chef de file de toute une génération de
talents totalement imprégné du souffle
frais d'un art qui marquera le début du
20e siècle
sarah bernhardt a besoin
un soir de noël d'une affiche pour son
spectacle nouveau une semaine plus tard
et
l'imprimeur lemercier la personne sauf
celui qui se trouvait là par hasard et
qui à qui il demande un essai essai qui
s'avère des plus concluants sarah
bernhardt tombe sous le charme de cette
nouvelle proposition l'impriment un
nouveau format à la fiche de 13 ans
auteur un peu kakémonos japonisant
courant qui devient très très influent
dans les arts décoratifs et l'image à
paris à la même époque et qu'il mâtine
un esprit byzantin avec une espèce de
solennité religieuse et sculpturale qui
donne à sarah bernhardt tout en
conservant le côté féminin
suggestif de la couleur aux couleurs
très travaillé
[Musique]
les techniques d'alors bouleverse les
usages la lithographie fait des prodiges
et les chefs d'oeuvre du maître commence
à envahir le monde mais micha
visionnaire veut voir plus loin il veut
voir plus large
c'est un des premiers à développer un
style néo on va dire d'un grand art ce
sapin train illustrateur pour quelque
chose qu'on appellerait aujourd'hui le
design graphique qui entend rendre
l'utile de nécessaire beau et donc
adapter un style genre d'image à des
formes à des volumes est même
complètement différent complètement
nouveau pour qu'il garde quelque chose
d'attrayant de beaux et micha ira plus
loin encore et toujours une rencontre en
forme de coup de coeur
cette fois ci je te fouquet le joaillier
une carte blanche pour un chef-d'oeuvre
c'est d'oeuvres d'art total donc chaput
déployés concrètement mettre en
application son son art graphique et
inventif avec la commande que lui fait
georges fouquet en 1900 d'une nouvelle
boutique rue royale qui va concevoir
entièrement intérieur extérieur et
bijoux proprement dit ainsi
qu'évidemment des éléments graphiques de
promotion
[Musique]
mais comme il le dira lui même le chat
ne trouve pas de véritable satisfaction
dans le travail décoratifs il rêve de
choses plus élevés pour trouver la
lumière dit il dans les coins les plus
reculés francs-maçons actifs et ardent
défenseur du peuple slave niche à toute
sa vie développera un art qu'il veut
libérateur c'est quelqu'un qui
profondément est attaché à une vision de
l'art à une cause une cause par laquelle
l'art doit libérer l'homme et l'ogg
c'est d'abord son peuple le peuple
tchèque et les peuples slaves ceux qui
sont sur la domination de l'empiré
austro hongrois
et très tôt il a ça en tête et au delà
de l'épisode affichiste parisien qui au
fond dure 5 6 ans et donc peu de temps
il a en tête donc de revenir à cette
cause là et de servir son peuple
[Musique]
oui
l'épopée slave un travail de titan vingt
toiles gigantesques un appel éclatant à
l'unité du peuple qu'il chérit un
travail de mémoire hors du commun dont
usa sacrifiera vingt années de sa vie
reclus dans un château de bohème c'est
un peintre qui cherche profondément à
émouvoir a touché à séduire d'abord mais
après à violenter quelque part avant ses
grands tableaux de l'épopée slave des
choses parfois très sont très noirs avec
des figures qui ont des expressions
tragique
donc les expressions sont très marqués
il veut interpeller le spectateur
celui qui voit ses oeuvres pour voilà le
faire réfléchir
son rôle qui peut jouer dans le destin
collectif
les jeunes fif leur idéal et parisienne
s'en sont allés laissant la place à la
marche d'un peuple dont micha se veut
l'extraordinaire metteur en scène il
faut profondément d'un point de vue
plastique dire cette grande série ne
serait ce que par son format comme une
espèce de projets cinématographiques par
grand plan grands plans fixes parce que
ça la monumentalité d'un écran de cinéma
et le côté monumentale des grands films
de griffiths qui raconte l'histoire
donc si c'est en effet une dimension on
va dire spirituel ou parfois émotive qui
ont présidé au choix de chacun de ces
épisodes
[Musique]
plutôt tiède fut l'accueil réservé à
l'épopée slave trop imposante trop
académique au regard de l'avant garde de
la jeune peinture de l'est mais micha
rêve encore des rêves qui
s'assombrissent comme les couleurs des
années tragiques qui s'annonce tout au
fil des années 30 et devient de plus en
plus pessimistes alors peut-être que le
relatif échec de second rang 9 l'a
poussé dans ses dérives sont bons aussi
là je mets aussi l'expérience on va dire
politique donc très très inquiet de ce
qui allait venir et donc il a va dire
hausser d'un cran son art dans le
symbolisme et l'appel aux grandes
valeurs qui doivent gouverner le monde
selon lui de la sagesse de la raison de
l'amour c'est les 3 titres d'un cran en
triptyque qu'il ambitionnait de faire à
la toute fin de sa vie et puis du côté
du puissant voisin allemand une grande
inquiétude en tant que franc maçon et
grand maître de la loge maçonnique de
prague il sera arrêté soumis à la
question et
voilà trois mois après il meurt vous
dire qu'en effet la gestapo à hâter sa
la fin de sa son riche parcours
[Musique]
c'est un peintre qui a voulu donner à
l'art une identité à la fois cech à la
fois slave et au fond derrière tout ça
profondément humaniste du maine est donc
à chercher l'identité de l'homme et de
sa position dure la terre si je peux
dire entre une dimension cosmique qui
l'a sondé de façon très profonde et une
dimension très très matérielles très
immédiate
[Musique]
oh
où